Так. Де тут запис.
Запис розпочато і сподіваюсь, у гарному гуморі, ми спробуємо якраз із вами розпочати адже як ми сьогодні на початку згадували де був і я був на опівночі, Європи, сьогодні день Європи, до речі, так що всіх зі святом погли Володимирович, запрошуємо.
фактично на який буде тримати в собі інформацію про користувача, Звісно, є багато різних способів як це ви можете зробити?
які в нас є варіанти, підключень, так ми можемо використовувати чіткі дані тобто користувач та його пароль, це 1 із видів прямій про те чи є це дуже гарним варіантом.
Не зовсім тому, що По-перше, такі питання дуже легко вкрасти Тобто, якщо хтось побачить ваших кран, то він може просто сфотографувати дані підключення і підключитись до вашої бази даних.
Такий підхід не є дуже га проте інших варіантів немає інший же підхід, наприклад, який також використовується у сервісі, убу це все ж таки, використання ключів.
токин Це просто рядок, розшифрований за допомогою деяких алгоритмів, який має якусь інформацію в собі при тому, що інформація є може бути будь-яка це може бути ім'я користувача, його вікна тобто будь-які дані про користувача, і фактично будь-хто маючи цей топк Звісно, може отримати
частковий доступ до цих даних проте ну некон і все ж таки, як це буде виглядати в реальній мікросервісній архітектурі, яку ми розглядаємо цю частину ми сьогодні будемо розробляти трошки простіше для того, щоб не створювати додатково ускладнення проте розглянемо як території.
Це може виглядати у більш великий проєкт, тобто в нас є частина клієнта, все ж таки, мабуть, є Га.
Зітроль напишу тут буквика що мене трошки збільшу Чудово, а і тут у нас буде.
стрілочку і тут якийсь там.
Так, клопіт не буду писати Все це Займете трохи часу, Тому Погляньмо просто Ми там Хочемо увійти, зрозуміло, що точку доступу.
відправляє.
Ви маєте доступ до Так. На Клієнт мафія. Така.
А так і от автор серветоризації, нам повертає якийсь токер і ми отримаємо дані для користувача.
Кажемо Назва також підпорядку. Тобто ми отримали далі. І тепер ми хочемо ще якісь запити робити що для цього потрібно нам робити Звісно, мікроссервісна архітектура, має і свої проблеми а в тому що сервер?
Немає взагалі ніяких можливостей. Для того, щоб підтвердити цей тотик Тобто сайт сам по собі існує просто незалежно йому не важливо чи я там якась авторизація, чи немає він просто робить запити його це не бентежить Тобто у нас є сиру авторизації.
себе: авторизації іперативно чи працює наш ток-шоу зробив токан чи ніхто його не вкрав і чи Взагалі він був згенерований лише на Ось цьому ректоризації, тому що це є дуже важливим.
змогли завантажити на відхаб в цьому випадку відбувається те ж саме. Тобто ми генеруємо якийсь дуже великий ключ який було дуже важко підібрати.
практикою є не зберігати втокині дуже специфічних даних, скажімо, пароль ми не хочемо, щоб який можна публічно без секрету, був у нас якийсь пароль.
Власне, таке це є вся сутність. Цього підходу. І це авторизація якщо ми додамо ще декілька серверів.
Це буде? Нас кисть, там.
Повернемось мабуть, такі до Джол-студі-код.
Так.
Чудово.
О, давайте збільше трохи екран.
наприклад, дотеп і ми використовували відповідний відповідно до бібліотек.
Давайте створимо новий термінал. І спробуємо встановити.
Пенсіон Високий? Так. Потрібно.
Ще раз Я Вiнкнув командний рядок Так.
Встановлюємо чудово. Нас Він є в пакеті на нас Він додався і ми можемо вже почати його досить легко.
сенс в яких випадках, генерувати токи перше ну, ми можемо звісно, генерувати його на етапі реєстрації, про це не завжди є ефективно.
приймала пароль та ім'я користувача і робила якийсь запит.
об'єктів. Тут вони будуть просто зберігати ступінь дати трошки більше використала тут об'єкт і ми можемо вказати я наприклад, хочу лише ім'я користувач і ми його і використали 1 штука буде мати ім'я користувачів.
Ці дані не є занадто небезпечними для того, щоб відправляти до клієнтської частини так, як зловмисники не отримають ніякої користі, від того, що вони мають Звісно, нашим ніякої столиці і далі.
етапі нам не важливо, щоб Він був занадто складний Це нам буде лише важливо, коли ми будемо робити реальний додаток, тому тут скажемо а наш секрет, і далі.
зайти на цей сайт з використанням стіл експаєр і Ми їм це не дозволимо в якийсь період звісно, це має і проблему тощо.
доцільним варіантом. І ми будемо його використовувати чому ми зробили токи. Хочемо Тепер його відправити візьмеш це буде оста.
Тобто тепер згенерувавши наш доки ми маємо дуже легко отримати доступ до наприклад, до нашого сенсу, і можемо якраз таки спробувати для цього напустимо наш сервер.
Чи Так, ми під'єднались до бази даних А Так, тепер мені знадобиться відкрити нашу частину фронтаду.
В 1 момент.
Чудово! А так і тепер зміню демонстрацію прагну довго просто демонстрації округу.
Остаточна альпіадреса якщо я правильно розумію так, у наших колег через те, що насамперед з динамічною епіадресою може знадобитися ну чи не кожного разу відповідно вносити або діапазон або надавати можливість томунгобі з усіх адрес це можливість робити.
Так.
згенерувався і ми його дуже легко можемо використовувати, що цей допит, це ми можемо взагалі його дуже легко перевірити, за допомогою відповідного сервісу який називається.
Аа це Сервес просто дершифрує ваші дані та щось у нас є приклад.
використовуємо на минулому. Кроці. І як бачите, ось в нас є ім'я користувача.
Моє коли він був Бачите? І Ед вони вказують що це з починаючи кількість секунд, яка минула, з 1 980-го року, і ось коли він в нас все ж таки буде вже неправильним Тобто, Бачите, вони трошки різняться тична так Бачите, 3 600 секунд.
хочемо користувачі так ми хочемо їх захистити щоб ніхто не міг зробити запит поки що давайте працюємо з клієнтської частини, а По-перше, вулиця блоги нам треба зберегти цей ток.
Тут може бути декілька способів перший спосіб створити глобальну зміну і використовувати а просто зміну і зберігати в неїток так Проблема є в тому, що такий підхід буде працювати лише до поки ви не оновите сталін в той простіший спосіб.
Звісно, він не є рекомендованим в більшості про те для сервісів. Можна використовувати такий підхід це локальне так.
Блокл. Сторож Ось у нас він є фактично це просто така невеличка паза ключів та їх значень.
спеціану функцію, Ось яка вже у нас є Зміна локл-стот і вона пропонує декілька методів, фактично досить просте це клієр китайм які Перемивайте міста тобто отримання відповідних даних їхнє прибирання Повна очистка, і задавань.
Сад Альтем та створять нову пару ключа та значення для відповідного ключа який ми хочемо його зазначити: тобто нам потрібно спершу цезначити ключ, а це туди.
І далі йому якесь значення, значення, в нас приходить вибори спогад кицю тобто.
Так Давайте тепер спробуємо повернутись, і випробувати все ж таки, Чи буде воно у нас працювати.
Коно на сторінку бачимо щось на слово сторож поки що пустої Але ми спробуємо зайти до сайту бачимо що потоки на вже зберігся і тепер якщо я буду оновлювати сторінку, також контрол файл бачите, в нас немає ніяких проблем.
хотіли з користуватися. Ми вказуємо.
І тут ми хочемо вказати Так, отой жеш Тобто, автор зять. І як його значення.
Нам потрібно казати слово бере Пробіл та на штоки І знову ж таки, отримати токаль можна звідси я в Тому ж саму Піч.
власне, таке серверний Нам потрібно розробити спеціальний функціонал, Для того, щоб перехоплювати наші задумки як це можна зробити дійсно найпростіший Мабуть, спосіб це прописати в кожний точок тоступор як тут наприклад, якісь функції?
Якими щоб вона перевіряла, А от такий-от в такому запиті, з таким заголовком у нас є такий далі проте в цьому є декілька проблем, По-перше, якщо скажімо, у вас буде набагато більший додаток, в якому будуть 1 000 рядків, коду, є великий.
Шанс того, що ви забудете вказати дані на початку і якась точка доступу залишиться весь захист такий спосіб я дуже поганий а звісно, маленьких додатків, це може спрацювати круто.
Експрес Я сам пропонує. Вже готовий функціонал Він називається міллея Фактично, можна це як назвати людина посередині це буде функція, яка буде виконуватися.
Між тим, як Запит прийшов до серверу і Між тим, як запит хоче виконати відповідну функцію, а тобто ця функція не буде виконана поки нам ось ця функція перевірки не поверне те, що можна далі.
Щось робити.
Ми можемо створити Загалом, це вказується ось тут третім параметром. Як ви бачите, якщо ми додамо зараз тут кому а за що тіло цього методу може приймати 3 вперше це шлях другої це гендер Тобто ті, що щось будуть робити, це може бути будь-що Ну, і третя це звісно ж, кластики.
Наш запит є так що приберемо її Спробуємо створити функції і саме її.
Ось так Я-м вона досить допростує в нас і буде складати з трьох частин.
Підних параметрів. Це у нас буде реквест той спонс і нес анекс нам потрібен для того, щоб вказати ми хочемо продовжити.
Тому, що інакше в нас немає дуже багато різних підходів, яким би чином можна було вказати що Ну, от все добре, ми хочемо продовжити звісно, можна розвивати це по-іншому.
Проте ось офіційний шлях. Таке бачимо ска детальніше. Зараз як саме таке він використовує а тепер нам потрібно зробити.
Перший це отримати наш головок авторизацій, для цього ми можемо використовувати А: Твойте це скажемо рун це ми можемо використовувати 3 квест і в ньому в нас є гедос.
І ось тут ми можемо власників вказати авторизації.
Тобто, ми так. Отримуємо весь наш відправний. Загалом проте як ви пам'ятаєте, він у нас складається з двох частин.
Це перер і власне-таки токи. Берег нам не потрібен ми не хочемо з ним нічого робити.
Не потрібен в цьому випадку, тому ми хочемо його ігнорувати, а ми хочемо отримати токе.
Давайте тоді беремо як ми пам'ятаємо, територіальльні рішення. У нас складаються з Ось такого рядка.
Де є 1 проб'єкт і цей Пробіл власне і те, що нам потрібно ми хочемо використати функцію спліт яка доступна для всіх рядків джерел стрибки і як сепаратор вказати йому Пробі та розіб'є наш рядок на 2 на 2 складових і ми хочемо отримати другу його складову а саме такі
Далі. Мета під нас є вже тока можемо, це протестувати для того, щоб бачити що наш мілгород працює і поки що скажімо, текст ось так що ми хочемо, щоб.
Воно не викликав ніяких проблем, тобто просто вивели токи, що ми його отримали.
В піємо север і Давайте його запустимо знову так, тоді повертаємось і я пам'ятаю, що ми зробили Кет-п'ютер який отримає в нас потока і давайте спробуємо зробити Запит так і бачимо що в нас є проблема що не можемо прочитати так у нас ось це не працює.
Мені здається, що треба вказати з маленької букви в експресі спробуємо ось так, щоб нас ви Загалом, підказували з маленької букви і спробуємо ще раз.
Так, все ще тоді перевіримо чи взагалі ми відправляємо?
Так ми не відправляємо це за заголовку як видно, аа спробуємо тоді розібратися в чому власне у нас є проблеми так можливо, я просто не оновив сторін.
Давайте спробуємо та в нас тут що нам непотрібно, було.
Так все ще немає токин я бачу про те, чомусь.
У нас хедер не розпізнається даному випадку.
Ти у давайте додамо трохи зрозуміти, чи взагалі ось ця частина в нас працює можливо, ще просто токане не генерують як і всі так? Добре, тобто в нас він згенерувався Проте ми все що отримаємо 500 як проблем.
Павло Володимирович, можливо, просто подивитися на хейдерс у цілком який ми отримаємо там щодо з типом даних може це не п'ятуком.
Ані біс. А я бачу, що можна отримати тут ми бачимо, заголовок так давайте було до моїх на екран, для того, щоб розуміти краще трохи що власне так і сталося.
перехопили.
Тепер нам Власне, такий треба зробити декілька перевірок Сша уявимо що топень взагалі не відправили ми можемо це зробити ось Таким чином, перевірку вже у скрипці.
Якщо ви просто вказуєте об'єкт чи то рядок якщо він просто пустий тут, у вас крипті, в умовних операторах, перетворить на булі це зручно тому що вам не треба перевіряти чи не є він пустим, чи не є він там і звісно ж, тут операція логічного ні, і тоді якщо ми знаємо, що у нас є
Проблема Ми не хочемо далі. Користуючись дозволяти будь-що, і ми зробимо бітують і Ну, хай це буде стати 401 Анна!
Турист що показуємо що не не мають вони доступу, і вкажемо якийсь там половчий сон.
Ера? Хто?
Тобто, нам потрібно і давайте тепер спробуємо.
Так. Так. Вертаймось.
Я не запустив. Сервер вибачаюсь.
Повертаємося і спробуємо зробити ще раз, але тепер ми приберемо ось тут ми можемо це редагувати легко бачите частина клієнт має доступ повний і скажемо зробимо якийсь запит.
є то ми хочемо зробити і говорить кать як зазначала, Сферифікація робиться за допомогою нашого кредит а Тут ми робимо з вами так звісно, і ось тут у нас є метод веріфай за допомогою цього методу ми півкаш.
Бачите, він у нас складається з трьох частин. Перше це ток-шоу він вже є друга це секрет, який у нас також є І третє це в нас просто опці серед опції. Ми можемо казати: ось такий ось.
Для зворотного зв'язку. Тобто що буде у випадку якщо в нас буде якась помилка або буде не буде помилок ми бачимо, 2 параметри ера Наприклад, і є кажемо користувач тут бачите ось нас нам пропонують так можна перше це помилка.
Друге це наш такдований режимті. В нашому це юзерни.
використати.
Так в нашому випадку буде фортепіано Тобто заборонено.
Фактично можна і 401 але ці статуси є просто для того, щоб розуміти клієнту що не так і скажемо що нам хочуть також ще й сон ен.
Еруть токан, проте треба не забувати у нас тут є важлива частинка. Як бачите, в цьому випадку я виписую в реченні тобто повернення про те, в цьому випадку я цього не використав нам треба це додати так.
також будуть працюватинув простіше вип випаде ось так добре і тоді або або навіть не потрібно ел, списати ми можемо просто написати далі ми отримали скажімо дані про користувача, і ми вже маємо коли ми хочемо.
Додати цього користувача Ну нашого запиту це досить легко. Можемо просто додати його як значення Ну ось таким чином, і далі використаємо анекс щоб все добре, ми хочемо йти далі і ось ціль 2 рядки можна забрати.
А тобто ми зробили ось такий простенький до березня, і давайте спробуємо його запустити.
Нашим працюю. Давайте По-перше, ми отримаємо 403 Тепер скажімо, я там повернутися на ось цей сайт, і нам тут.
Пропонували якийсь стан ток-шоу я скопіюю розвідці і буду намагатися сюди, його додати Давайте спробуємо зробити запит побачимо що наші 403 говорять що токи, не є правильним.
що імелі цикничок, це неправильний підпис і підпису нам у даному випадку є ось цей секрет 1, 2, 3, 4.
Добре, все ж таки, давайте тепер зробимо коректно ми будемо увійдемо як користувач, то нашого себеру і будемо намагатися з вами тепер увійти ми отримали стоки і тепер якщо ми зробимо запит ми успішно отримаємо дані під користувача.
Які ми не могли отримати доцю е і Ось таким чином ми з вами зробили найпростіший перевірку даних, хід це нам забезпечує дуже простенький захист. Дійсно ми можемо додати Ось сюди до нашого.
До нашого підпису можемо додати більше даних і це насправді має сенс, тому що ми можемо сюди, наприклад, є також дуже важливим для нас це конкретна роль користувача.
адекватно використовувати відповідні ролі такими, також можемо, швидко додати скажімо, що я хочу зробити павло адмінкористуваче так і ми там, додамо, ще одне з вами поле яке буде відповідати за роль ну поки що не для найпростішого.
Придбання Зараз Нам потрібна нова реєстрація.
Так скажемо, що буде роль.
Так тоді повернемось функцію, і ми будемо відправляти для реєстрації, скажімо, 3 частини цко ж подорой яку ми з вашим чином отримали.
адміністратор вже буде визначатися ну скажімо, там прямо з риба даних це є найадекватнішим варіантом тому що Таким чином, складніше отримати доступ до будь-яких ваших даних і далі.
Ми хочемо додати. До нашого А.
Так. Себе. Ми додали Так, зберігаємо далі. Ми хочемо додати до нашого цебору.
Скажімо, точку доступу, для лише ведення адміністраторів і ми не знаємо її ну от якусь скажімо, там.
Ледь створено нову Адмін.
Хай також будуть Користувачі поки що не будемо нічого створювати додаткового про те, спробуємось так.
Тепер, коли ми маємо ось це ми хочемо також ми додамо те, що нас. І в минулому.
Є прикладі Ну, скажемо, що це буде прочитувати користувач у цьому випадку, це просто як деякі приклад що у нас також.
Тепер Ми хочемо пластики. Захистити ми зможемо Звісно, додати аукціонер.
реєстрації ми отримуємо тут також роль і давайте додамо збереження цієї ролі вовк вас дане.
А ось у нас так виходить ну і поки що давайте перевіримо будь ласка, чи буде в нас працювати.
Так взагалі так тут перезавантажимо і додамо там якесь пекло.
Ах, ми ж Се буде мій.
Адміністраторський і ось тут скажемо Адмін і відправив бачимо що нас са Добре, і тепер давайте отримаємо всіх користувачів.
От Павло Амнес. Тут є.
І як бачите, ми ось отримали роль адміністратор а всі й інших поки що він немає, але цих користувачів, і давайте створимо павлою, це буде просто користувач.
Ну, чому йосип ми додали а отримаємо всі користувачі і ось в нас є павлою який буде з роллю користувача.
Тепер ми Власне, таки хочемо зробити. Ось це працює. Як нам перевіряти Звісно, ми це також зробимо за допомогою вр Проте в даному випадку, нам треба буде перевіряти так.
Що ми отримаємо ось тут Тобто на етапі верифікації.
Так, ми можемо Звісно, повністю це скопіювати.
Давайте трошки спростимо і поки що створимо ось таку це все, ми можемо перенести бо відповідно, функцію, зробити це більш адекватно, Але давайте на даному етапі поки що зробимо це найпростішим шляхом, додамо до ось цієї функції.
Якусь перевірку по ролях але просто капілюють і скажімо, це у нас буде.
Емігрує а тобто схожий до того буде робити всі ті ж самі функції, проте з єдиною відмінністю що ми хочемо все ж таки Давайте це термінами, під а далі.
Ось тут.
Скажімо що ми хочемо вивести ці дані тобто отримати що ми там бачимо взагалі але ми їх отримуємо і підемо далі тепер давайте повернемось перезавантаження, сервер.
Тобто, ми просто хочемо зараз, глянути що ми отримуємо як дані коли верифікували що то ким правильний.
Повернемось. І використаємо скажімо, Павло ю натискаємо логи. Повертаємось, Так, звісно. Що я забув.
Казати ось тут, наш Адмін Недовбий А І ще 1 момент, який нам потрібен це кнопку для того, щоб отримати запити це класики.
Адміністратора, ми поки що просто додамо.
Адмін якось.
Це виглядало що це конкретно. Для адміністрації це сет мін'юсту.
І просто так само, як минулого разу, просто скопіюємо ось цю функцію. Нашу ага.
Назвамо її весь адмін'юзер і ну вона не буде нічого робити, хоча можемо і лишити нам не є.
Різниця якась їм так, нас буде розказати ток-шоу так, нам треба перезавантажити сервер.
І Давайте ще раз. Спробуємо зайти.
До наших користувачів ну, і отримати дані як адміністратор, тут ми зробили запит до іншої точки доступу і що ми отримали бачите, так ми отримали Сьюзерне.
Тому що ми забули додати ці дані до нашого топеня давайте це зробимо можна ось простоторка справді вказувати якщо ім'я однакове з ім'ям, відповідної пропорції, тому зберігаємо і давайте спробуємо перегенерувати токами, там у нас апарол ізно-дефайд так.
А звісно, тому що я її тут не отримав ми її отримаємо користувача, вона все ж таки тут треба буде зробити ось так і від користувача, ми отримаємо ось цю роль так само, як метри тому що цей користувач, це те, що ми отримаємо в зоопарку так зберігаємо перезавантаження серверт.
І давайте спробуємо ще раз от, Чудово! Ми увійшли і тепер можемо навіть перевірити наш токан Чи взагалі він буде мати відповідні дані бачите у нас з'явилася роль користувач.
Давайте перевертаємось і робимо ще 1 запит до отримання користувачів.
Так бачимо, що тепер у нас є роль, користувач тобто це фактично об'єкт, який в нас матиме всі ці дані, які має просто ділити.
одразу. Там повертаємо якийсь статус 400 скажемо 3 Не можна вам сюди.
Мі скажемо Що якась там Ее.
Яка ж, помилка, там сталася якщо ж, звісно роль буде адміністратор, то все буде так, давайте тепер спробуємо перезавантаження, наш сервер.
перевіряти. Це якимось іншим. Чином тут у нас є адміністратор ми перевіримо роль.
це може бути 1 і та ж люди, і нам немає різниці, якоїсь яка в неї є роль, А в цьому випадку, нам це є є важливим, давайте тепер спробуємо я тоді створював користувача, Павло А який ми також спробуємо увійти перевіримо що ми отримали як токи.
От бачимо що Павло а в нас є адміністратор. Що нам не потрібно давайте тепер створимо, зробити, запит і бачите, що ми успішно отримали, доступ і при тому що ми будемо мати доступ до обох точок доступу, з адміністраторами.
З користувачами загалом, як бачите, ми досить такі простим шляхом. Можемо це вже пробрати ми досить простим шляхом.
Розробили Базово функція людина посередині Тож функції. Посередині яка нас перевіряє ось такий от базовий функціонал у ваших тотаках навіть якщо це буде менстропедія, чи магазин будь-що.
них Данія, наприклад, ціну тому що Уявімо, що ви там розробляєте свій додаток комусь і та людина не має технічних знань, тому звісно, ви можете все включити в ешкемель проте на жаль, це не завжди є гарним варіантом.
Ну, мабуть, немає.
Ну, якщо так, я думаю, що ми цілком можемо спробувати з вами, тоді зробити пахінацію Проте ми не встигнемо її зробити повністю але можемо лише почати і на наступному занятті.
Тоді?
Павлович якщо не встигнемо можливо, дійсно краще перенести це повністю на наступне заняття а сьогодні, як то кажуть на честь свята, спробувати вважати що ми виконали поставлену задачу.
Так я думаю, що це буде кращим варіантом для того, щоб все ж таки мати краще розуміння і все було в одному занятті, і легше переглядати і сприймати.
Дякую. Павло Володимирович, Ну Тоді як То кажуть, щоб не розпочинати нову тему.
Давайте спробуємо зробити річку. Перекличку? У вас вдається.
Було питання: не до представників другої команди чи Я помиляюсь.
Так я бачу. Що в нас усі Олександр Загалом, хотілося б почути, прогрес по проєкту зрозуміти, Чи є якісь проблеми взагалі на якому етапі у вас є проєкт вашої команди?
Олександр Євгенович Ви з нами.
Мабуть.
Так А і тi можливо. Е, Станіслав я бачу, є у нас Так, італій. Чи був?
Душею.
Якийсь прогрес з вашого боку чи вже спланували приблизний кількість роботи, яку треба закінчити до презентації.
No doubt. My…
Тоді саме час завершувати пропоную розширено велику перерву, зробити цього разу а іншого разу можливо, доведеться трохи затриматися так, і буває.
Добре ну.
Дякую. Усім до швидкої зустрічі з кимось ми Зустрінемося Сьогодні на відповідному передзахисті.
Не з кимось зустрінеться і Павло Володимирович у середу остання п'ятницю Ну і також передостаннє не практичне заняття так що здоров'я Наснаги і до зустрічі на все добре.
Не так. Звучить.
Yeah.
Дякую. Покликання Я не надсилав.
Значить. Потрібно сьогодні. Ця буде зробити Дякую.
Тут почне.
На Все добре. До побачення.